a southeast valley neighborhood is on
edge tonight after some say a serial
arsonist is terrorizing their community
thanks for joining us at 11 i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis neighbors
say multiple cars have been set on fire
in the span of just a couple of days
only on eight orco man alive in studio
to break down their concerns and what
police are doing about it orco well
brian and denise this is all happening
in a neighborhood here just south of
makira airport we're going to zoom in to
give you a little bit of a closer look
here now neighbors tell us that the
vehicle fires were set during three
separate incidents
over here here and here and you can see
that they're pretty close together now
the community just wants answers
a fire ripped through a couple cars
tuesday night at a home near warm
springs and easter now all that's left
is charred metal and broken glass it's
terrible that these people are going
through this we don't know exactly
what's going on neighbors tell me
they're seeing fire damage like this
outside not just one home not just two
homes but three homes in the area and
the community is shaken up that's
especially true because the vehicle
fires happen so close together all in
the span of a few days metro has
official reports of two fires including
this one from early monday morning which
police tell us started as a family
disturbance neighbors believe a serial
arsonist is disrupting their normally
quiet community all of a sudden out of
nowhere it just starts and then you're
wondering what's going to happen is ours
going to be the next one clark county
confirms its fire department is doing a
joint investigation with metro police
into the vehicle fires and tells us
quote the fires appear to have been
intentionally set but who is behind them
the neighbors around here do have an
idea of who it might be this man who
wanted to remain anonymous believes the
culprit is someone who has a history of
disturbing the neighborhood we don't
know for sure while the investigation
continues and police pick up patrols
neighbors pray for one thing i just hope
this doesn't happen again
now i tried speaking to the homeowners
for each of the vehicle fires happened
but they told me they were afraid to
speak due to potential retaliation stay
with eight news now as we learn more
from investigators in the studio orco
mano live local now